so you never had an imaginary friend
because you had a little no we're trying
to survive bro we're like [__] what do
we eat we just had imaginary dads
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you guys believe that little kids can
see ghosts yup a thousand percent and I
also believe that until they are past
the age of three or four they're still
confused if they're in their past life
or current life because they're
reincarnated interesting I think kids
are filthy Little Liars
[Music]
um
I think they're like Master manipulators
too
yeah you know why they're so [__]
cute in the face because if a full-grown
adult did that [__] I'll beat them up
that's for sure a thing it's like a
genetic thing for sure and then so
humans are just like damn it you're so
[__] cute I can't do it man yeah you
have to take care of you you're such a
[__] that Punchy little cute little
[__] face especially with like with
my kids now I feel the exact same way
but if a full-grown adult does the same
thing man I [__] slap the living life
out of them do you believe that when
kids have imaginary friends and maybe
you guys did when you were kids yeah I
tried I really wanted to have imaginary
friend I just used imagination stuff do
it yeah I did have an imaginary friends
just because I was a loser what was
describe your imaginary friend
I don't remember his name was it a ghost
remember any traits
um I remember it was just like me was he
funny
and I was I was the only child so I was
I just had to create a space where like
I get to like lay in bed and then put my
blanket over him and then we get to like
talk dude you guys slept together yeah
set that on fire set it on fire it's
just your intrusive thoughts
I bet you won't set that on fire idiot
and he's like oh yeah check this out I
had imaginary pets
pets yeah pets like really like I don't
know if you could do that yeah you could
do that [__] I would I would I would
make up like cats and animals and [__]
and did you have any like exotic ones
like oh this is my pet tiger Dragon
that's pretty badass that's kind of cool
I had a little brother so there was no
imaginary for me yeah oh he had a real
one yeah the real ones beat his ass beat
his ass and he deserved it though huh he
had to come in though quite deserved it
no did he so did he have an imaginary
friend no dude I always have imaginary
nurse
yeah oh I wanted a brother
not to like that you have a brother yeah
but he's 12 years older it's like having
a third parent yeah yeah mine was a year
younger Dad too like a more closer
brother oh and I the thing is I I like
after I was like two he was already gone
because they sent him to boarding school
so it's like by the time he's 14 he's
gone so I'm like man I want to play with
my brother every time in the summer like
like he would he would put me on my
skateboard and just like put me downhill
and [__] and like you know I thought we
were playing but he was just [__]
with me you know that's like the big
brother thing yeah yeah you think it's
like you're both in on the joke yeah and
then he's like yeah yeah you want to go
down and like
um he says hold the skateboard and then
he throws me down the half pipe I'm like
yay and then I fall and then he's like
laughing with his friends and not
knowing that that was the funny thing I
just think I'm doing something cool
great day been there Colleen you didn't
have any imaginary friends no I grew up
with a brother like very close in age so
same how many how many how many uh kind
of like same situation
my brother who's like 10 11 years older
never saw him and then they use you for
entertainment yeah well he just wasn't
around uh and then um and then my
brother Lance who's a year and a day
older hmm you're in a day the closer
relationship though you can actually
play together and stuff yeah that's cool
I had an older brother too Stepbrother
[__] got kicked out to uh the army
oh because he was being out to them when
we were living in Hawaii he would get
into fights and fight all the Samoans
and everything and he would always go
smoking weed and everything
to my dad apart then my brother my dad
was like you know what
a little gift for you as soon as he
turned 18 some dude came by brought him
and said you're going to Korea for a
vacation oh go see Korea and got took it
straight to the Army oh the Korean army
Korean army
that's some crazy [__] that's the
mandatory two years right yeah yeah and
ever since then my brother's like yo
that's how they recruit Korean military
people back in the day yeah yeah so what
do you mean like how was his response to
being sent there the trick me [__]
[Laughter]
he's always like the cool cat so he's no
smoking in the room my pastor would come
in give me the Jackie you know they give
him all that I can throw chairs at him
my brother was just that's Korean Korean
and faster I'll [__] you up yeah
dude with the batter thing and then my
brother was just like I don't care and
then some dude grabbed him I'll beat the
holy ghost in your Beach yeah one day
just grab them took him to the airport
so you're going to Korea to visit your
family but nope straight to the Army so
he was pissed about like did he come
back a changed person like he couldn't
come back so he's in Korea he's in Korea
right now until this day so basically he
deported his own son he deported his own
son it was my stepfather older brother
God damn he's the one that took care of
me took me around to the basketball
court showed me the ways always got me
Legos and [__] gone damn dude
yeah talk to him now he's like yo [__]
dad
just mad
you never met your dad who beat his ass
huh what do you like [__] up your dad
yeah one day he would grab my dad would
grab my brother's throat boom in the
wall and I'll just watch like what the
[__] is going on if you want to play
basketball huh
you want to play basketball all day no
come late every day
but your brother doesn't have like a
Revenge mission to come back no no no
there was no Revenge Mission he was just
like my brother now my dad's in Korea
because one day my dad's there too yeah
because my dad called the Army himself
you're gonna go see your family okay
cool no one day my dad was just like hey
son I'll be back in a week and I was
like okay Dad see you soon
gone he's like I'm in Army now no no
that's the same filtration ten years
later he messages me 10 years 10 years
later what do you say
how are you doing
did you take care of Mom I'm like
[__] that's your job
I take care of us what
10 years you you were just guessing what
happened you just yeah I just bounced on
you yeah we were in like Elementary
Middle School yeah and I was like yo
when's he coming back Dad um Mom when's
he coming back I want to pierce my ears
oh this and that and one just never came
back that's [__] he bounced on you
and your mom my mom and my little
brother he he bounced and then my and
then I that's when I saw my whole family
crumble because my dad was the money
maker oh [__] so my mom didn't know how
to do it so she would be working 6 a.m
to 6 a.m wow but I was like yo what
what's open that [__] it that's why you
got a thousand jobs huh that's why you
got a thousand jobs that's why I got a
thousand jobs
whoa that's crazy that's true I was like
Mom what's open up what the hell what
the [__] are you doing what I am mom
she's working overnight shift at the
factory or something how come you guys
didn't call the Army on yourselves too
so you all go over there because I was
trying to I was just painting walls at
those times we're just doing whatever we
want
stealing food
because we had to stealing pens just for
school but we didn't even go to school
but you want pants just a case
we could do it yeah oh it's back to
school we need to get it
stealing pads for school but you don't
go
yeah but but it was always me and my
little brother we were always doing the
same thing together uh so you never had
an imaginary friend because you had a
little no we were trying to survive bro
like [__] what do we eat just had
imaginary dads
[Laughter]
I'm only I'm only joking because it's
your life is like my dad left too so so
far I can relate did you ever imaginary
dad
I just bottled my friends
[Laughter]
you kind of you kind of have Role Models
though like so like my pop left at 14
too we just in the the way the the thing
is the freedom that you have is so fun
so far you don't think about how [__]
up it is right because your mom's like
too busy working all day she's probably
sad as [__] yeah as a kid you're
probably just coping because you just
don't know so we're just like out with
other [__] wild boys that have no
parents yes and then you're just like
Lord of the Flies like riding your bike
till like three in the morning you don't
give a [__] like going to Raves whatever
and then
you just get into the funnest [__] and
it's like some of the funnest times were
that I'm not gonna lie that was the best
time of my life graffiti bike cigarettes
right who bought a walk to school and
you turn around you're like [__] this
exactly you just don't go hey I left
your mom a bunch of voicemails I was
like oh keep leaving them she's just
busy but we didn't have the the money to
pay for the phone bill so I kept telling
the teachers yeah you gotta keep calling
her she's just busy
yeah kid hacks for us if after a second
period they they don't call roll so all
the kids after second period they just
left
yeah so I'm like I had a short school
day be out by 10. yeah only stay for
breakfast and I'm like there's the fence
let's go boys
down the fence we go and he just play
all day all day every day crazy smoke
and then and then um and then you have
like random male figures being Your Role
Models that's that's what would happen
but but then you start looking up to
like gangs like gangster dudes or like
whatever like you just you just have a
primitive idea of what a man is right so
the toughest guy that like can throw
down or like the guy that like protects
you or gives you money they're like oh
yeah this guy's he's a boss and then
like you look back and you're like oh
that guy was a 23 year old loser
that's what happened with me yeah it was
just always looking at gangsters and
like I want to be like him right and
then you have like an intelligent actual
good father figure but you look at them
you're like man he's a fat loser he's
he's so fat he can't fight he just what
is like yeah he's a loser how's he
supposed to protect us right but then
you're like you just look at the wrong
characters and then later on like you
actually go to a loving home and then
you see how their dad is their parents
are they're just like oh yeah this guy
is cool yeah yeah that's what happened
that guy's a fat loser is all I hear
no or dads that will take you out
bicycle ride Beach day then your whole
thing starts changing like oh this is
kind of cool man yeah I don't have to be
on the street I don't have to be on I'm
getting soft like I don't have to be on
the street anymore yeah I don't have to
smoke cigarettes because this [__]
guy's telling me to smoke cigarettes
yeah but cigarettes are pretty cool at
that time was it pretty cool yeah fresh
Lounge baby
[Music]